hi everyone in this video I would talk
about long-term depression now if we
break the term long term means long
lasting and reparation means weakening
so for long lasting synaptic weakening
could be termed as long term depression
here is our brain which is formed of
billions of neurons and they are
connected to each other by junctions
known as synapses now upon experience or
learning related tasks the strength and
transmission efficiency of these
synapses could change either increase or
decrease any decrease in synaptic
transmission efficiency and strength
which is long lasting is known as long
term depression now long term depression
could be evoked by some protocol in a
culture slice system people can people
can excite the presynaptic terminal and
they are able to record from the post
synaptic terminal in this situation if
they give a presynaptic current
injection they are going to get a
postsynaptic potential known as epsp now
people scientists have applied a
protocol which is a stimulation protocol
in which they give and 10 Hertz low
frequency stimulation for about 10
minutes and then they again give the
same amount of current injection after
the current injection what they have
noticed is the amplitude of the
postsynaptic potential decreased that
means the strength of the synapses has
been decreased right now another way of
showing this data is to plot the
calculate the slope and plot the slope
over time and if it is lower than the
baseline that's just the synaptic
strength has been altered now what
exactly happens when 100 huh when 10
Hertz for 10 minutes
low-frequency stimulus is given the low
frequency stimulus
raise the calcium level in the
postsynaptic region from 100 nanomolar
to 400 nano molar
unlike LTP this is quite low because in
case of LTP the postsynaptic calcium
elevation is 10 fold
it rises about 1 micromolar so this kind
of catch the fourfold calcium rise can
be detected by mechanisms but before we
have to show that Ltd is also
responsible for Ltd calcium is also
responsible and NMDA receptor has
profound role in Ltd because in case of
Ltd protocol if you block the NMDA
receptor by a NMDA receptor blocker the
long-term depression is gone here you
can see the the synaptic the epsp slopes
recorded over time is nearly paid like
baseline after 1 Hertz low frequency
stimulation depression didn't take place
because NMDA is blocked in this
situation but if the blocker is washed
out then you can see the synaptic strain
has has decreased from the baseline
that means depression had occurred for
Ltd concentration of the calcium and
also calcium entered by a via NMDA
receptor is important now also any Ltd
is highly dependent upon the frequency
of stimulation high-frequency
stimulation can give rise to
potentiation whereas low frequency
stimulation 1 Hertz to 10 Hertz
frequency stimulation can give rise to
Ltd now what's so special about
frequency of stimulation because if the
frequency of stimulation is high
potentiation could occur whereas the
total reversible type of change total
opposite kind of change happens when the
frequency of stimulation is low then the
whole concept is in calcium because low
frequency stimulus for a long duration
rise the calcium at a level which would
activate certain molecular mechanisms
which can depress the synaptic strength
instead of increasing now and and that
kind of lower level of calcium calcium
rise for a longer time could be detected
by molecular mechanisms like calcineurin
calcineurin can read the calcium signals
now here you can see that when
calcineurin is blocked the long-term
depression is gone both the cases either
by pharmacological blockage of
calcineurin or by blocking of calcium in
by a calcineurin inhibitor a peptide the
synaptic depression response for
recorded over time is gone
that means calcium urine is very
important for synaptic depression now
what just happened underlying NMDA
receptor calcium is there but in this
calcium the spatial temporal dynamics of
the calcium has very profound
implication whether the synaptic
strength would increase or the synaptic
strength would decrease now a brief high
level of calcium would increase the
synaptic strength while low level of
calcium persisting for a long time would
decrease the synaptic strength because
low and persisting level of calcium can
activate calcineurin which is a protein
phosphatase now calcineurin indirectly
in interfere with the chemical
reactivity and calcineurin also does
other stuffs which would allow a
depression in the synaptic strength and
also a structural change in the synaptic
synapses now here is the synapse let's
say there are three ampere acceptors and
one an MD receptor on this particular
synapse and you are able to inject a
current I'm going to record response
from the post synapse but then you give
a ltd induction protocol which is kind
of low frequency stimulation and lasting
for 10 to 15 minutes now what happens
after that when you inject the same
amount of current now you are able to
record a postsynaptic potential whose
amplitude is way lower than the earlier
but what actually happened
in case of LTP calcineurin type of
proteins theydo phosphorylated several
molecules as a result as a end result
AMPA receptors get internalized in the
postsynaptic region thereby the
postsynaptic current is decreased the
current amplitude is decreased it also
causes structural change as a result the
postsynaptic the postsynaptic region the
post synapse got smaller in size or this
size decreased because Cal syndrome can
also interfere with the actin
polymerization mechanisms but the
question is what Ltd actually does
people claim that LTP like mechanisms
could be used by the brain to encode
memory while ldd like mechanisms could
be used by the neuron in the brain to
erase memories but this kind of view is
debated and also very controversial
recent studies have shown that pink in
flies in Drosophila classical
conditioning wherein condition and
unconditioned stimulus here you can see
the Flies are trained with the order
which is coupled with a shock and also
separately trained with the order which
is not coupled with the shock if they
have learned their lesson properly they
would avoid the order which comes with a
shock when only the order is presented
now this kind of classical conditioning
underlying this kind of classical
conditioning scientists have found that
except at specific at specific synapses
between the fly learning center and the
output neuron which goes to the motor
center there is a synaptic depression
happening suggesting synaptic depression
could be also a part of this learning
processes and a mechanism underlying
which memory could be encoded but still
this kind of conclusion so no
conclusions could be drawn from this
kind of experiments and and it's only we
can say that this kind of processes are
underlying learning and mechanism but
exactly with that there is a causal
relationship we cannot claim till right
now I hope you like my video if you like
my video give it a quick thumbs up don't
forget to subscribe and thank you